[Music]
so
am i oh i'm on
good evening everybody welcome to the
table it is good to see you
both here and those who are joining us
online
thank you for coming to the table
tonight um
i just have one announcement before we
get started with worship and that is our
state of the table meeting
that is happening exactly one week from
tonight so next sunday immediately after
the service we're gonna have our state
of the table which happens
twice a year it only happens twice a
year so it is a special event it
qualifies as a special event here at the
table we would love for you to be a part
of it whether you're a member or not
it's just a great way to find out more
about us and it think of it like a big
family meeting
that's what it is we'll be talking
through different areas of our church
and our community leadership transitions
we'll talk about our finances we
basically just lay it all out there we
have a time for questions and answers so
it's something that you want to be a
part of so again that's next sunday 6 15
p.m here immediately after the service
we will also be
streaming that online as well so you can
either be here or watch online for that
all right
so
gosh you guys it has been another week
hasn't it
i mean the best way i can describe it
and i really don't think this is being
too dramatic it's been a bit of a
tsunami
of of things
and you can fill in the blank whether
it's been a tsunami of grief a tsunami
of sickness a tsunami of
just
um
climate change a tsunami of
humanitarian disaster
it's been a lot it's been a lot and
during times like this for me at least
it is so good to remember
that jesus is at the center
jesus is always at the center
jesus has never left
god is always with us
his love always surrounds us we don't
have to earn it we don't have to come to
church for it
we don't have to go looking for it
we don't have to measure up for it god's
love is always there so no matter where
you find yourself tonight if you're
doing pretty good god's love is here for
you
if you're feeling great god's love is
here for you if you're feeling heavy
god's love is here for you
if you're feeling not worthy god's love
is here for you if you're feeling just
ambivalent apathetic numb
avoidant god's love is here for you
so i hope that tonight
you feel that i hope you feel that for
yourself
not just up here in your head but here
in your heart and throughout your whole
body that you feel god's love god's
acceptance
god's care
and that god will never leave you no
matter what he is an anchor for our soul
that's true for me it's true for you
it's true for everybody watching so will
you pray for me pray for me yes
yes
truer words were never spoken
pray for me and pray with me
god thank you so much for your presence
your love that never leaves never fails
who we are what we have going on around
us is never too much for you god
and we hold on to that tonight
and we remember that we're not alone
we're surrounded by your love god we're
surrounded by the love of those in our
table community
by our siblings in christ
it's a big family
and we don't have to shoulder it on our
own
when i'm feeling weak there's somebody
else that has some strength for me when
i'm feeling sad
somebody has some hope for me
[Music]
and i can do the same for others
so god we
surrendered to you tonight
and we also thank you for that anchor
that you are of hope
the anchor of love
and that you are faithful god
so i ask that you meet us here tonight
wherever we find ourselves
and may ask may we experience that
together
in jesus name i pray amen
amen
thanks karen that reminded me of
romans 8. i just wanted to read that
before we kick off our worship time
i am convinced that nothing can separate
us from god's love
neither death nor life
neither angels nor demons
neither our fears for today
nor our worries about tomorrow
tomorrow
not even the powers of hell can separate
us from god's love
no power in the sky above or in the
earth below indeed nothing in all
creation will ever be able to separate
us from the love of god that is ours in
jesus
just meditate on that as we go into this
time
of singing together
that's really the heartbeat behind this
set is experiencing
um there's that specific love you know
that that we talk about where it's like
god
god loves you individually and then
there's also this love that gives me
hope right now in our current situation
where it's like there's also this larger
grander love of god that we are able to
tap into
when we as communities are feeling the
lack of hope and tonight i hope that as
a community we're able to kind of
connect with this larger picture of love
that's accessible you know he does love
us individually but also we come
together and in that we create the love
of god we find that and it finds us
we're swept up into this bigger thing
it's bigger than just me and my
experience of god it's about us together
with him
so um let's continue leaning into that
creation of god's love
as we sing i invite you guys to stand
and sing with us if you are able um
joe's going to kick us off and get us
started so y'all sing along where you
would like but you are welcome and
wanted in this space and i hope that you
do experience that sense of the of the
larger
um
togetherness that love of god that we
find together
[Music]
where can we run
where can we hide
[Music]
is there a place that we can go
where you cannot find us
you're there when we fall
there when we rise
[Music]
nothing is hidden from your face
you know every breath
we take
your love has found us your love has
found us
we are yours forever
your love has found us it's all around
us
holding us together
[Music]
nothing on earth
above or below
nothing in all the universe
can take us from your love
you came
[Music]
your love has found us your love has
found us
we are yours forever
your
it's all around us
holding us together
your love has found us your love has
found us
we are yours forever
it's all around us
holding us together
we will sing because your love has found
us even in the darkest nights we'll sing
because your love has set us free
[Music]
the darkest nights will sing because
your love has set us free
[Music]
it's all around us
holding us together
[Music]
it's all around us
holding us so we will sing because your
love has found us even in the darkest
nights we'll see because your love has
set us free
we will sing because your love has found
us even in the darkest nights we'll sing
because your love has set us free
[Music]
miss god would it continue to find us
here in the midst of whatever we're
processing through god would your love
find us here
[Music]
we've been hiding
in the shadows
lost and afraid
of you
we've been wandering
in the darkness
but if we own
[Music]
you
no
[Music]
you've been waiting
to show us mercy
your presence is
[Music]
is
we all know
[Music]
there is no fear
anymore
[Music]
cause you're the god of mercy
there is no fear
anymore
[Music]
there is
is
[Music]
we're going to enter into our prayers of
the people and um
if you've never been with us before this
is a tradition that dates back in
christian history
um and it's where we're able to join in
together with short prayers for people
or situations that we're carrying
on our hearts or in our minds
maybe something that's burdening you or
someone that you've been holding close
and you would like to share that with us
and we can all lift it up together
as a time to just
hold each other's burdens and believe
that god is with us in the midst of
those and listening and hearing us so
i'm gonna read through this prayer and
where you see red words on the screen we
can pray that together and then i'm
gonna open it up for a time for you guys
to share
a name or a situation that's on your
heart and then i will close us out at
the end
with another prayer
for the city of saxi texas god and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land see or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan for the injured for the
suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so right now we
lift these names and situations
up to you
and karen will share any that are shared
on our live feed online if you would
like to share those there as well
[Music]
from online bobby hole
nancy's kilo treatments
karen lega
chris
vicki
our pastors and leaders at the table
kelly
the family of gene benedict
[Music]
from online karen and daniel
from online
james townsend and all other teachers
[Music]
johanna
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
thank you guys
[Music]
yeah father god we thank you for who you
are
lord for your grace and your mercy
lord we become we come before you father
humbled
by your goodness
by your love
we invite you into our hearts and our
minds lord
help us to be at peace
and to sit at your feet tonight lord
we love you
[Music]
you are here
moving in our midst
worship you
i worship you
you are here
working in
[Music]
i this
you
i worship you
you are here
moving in
[Music]
you are here
working in this
i place
you
i worship you
you are
way maker miracle
in workers keep
my god that is who you are
you are
way maker miracle worker promise keeper
light
my god that is who you are
you are here
touching every heart
i worship you
[Music]
you are here
healing every heart
i worship you
[Music]
worship you
i worship you
[Music]
my god that is who you are
yes it is
you are way maker here it could work a
promise keeper not in the darkness my
god that is who you are
[Music]
my god that is
my god that is who you are
[Music]
who you are
that is who you are
[Music]
even when you don't see it
even when i don't see it you working
[Music]
i don't feel it you're working you never
stop you never stop working you never
stop you never stop
even when i don't see it's you again
even when i don't feel it you
[Music]
you never
my god
[Music]
my god that is who you are
my god that is
[Music]
is
i think it's so
helpful for me to remember that our god
is not tied to an outcome and he's not
tied to just one situation or one prayer
request
but that he is the force flowing through
each one of us
he is the unity that we experience when
we come together to carry each other's
burdens
he is the hope that we can tap into
jesus thank you for being more
than we see with our eyes or that we
understand with our minds god
even more than my individual experience
of you you are so much bigger and so
much better god and you have made room
and you've made space for each one of us
each one of our stories
and you invite us into this journey god
and we find
that you've been there all along loving
us calling us
creating in us
newness and beauty and life
thank you jesus that you're working even
when we're unaware of it
and when the light seems the darkest god
it's when we find you sparking within us
when our strength has run out god that's
when we feel you
rising up within us carrying us god
even when i don't see it you're working
even when i don't feel it you're working
you never stop you never stop working
you never stop you never
[Music]
sing that one more time together just
lift our voices even when i don't see it
you're working
even when i don't feel it you're working
you never stop you never stop working
you
[Music]
thank you jesus for this time together
will we find hope in our company would
we find love in the faces around us
would we experience you as a community
it's in your name i pray amen
and why don't we just take a moment to
turn to the people sitting around us and
just give a wave a smile through the
mask
offer that hope and sense of community
to others
[Music]
all right all right well good evening
grace and peace
welcome to the table
it is um just wonderful
wonderful to be here and um
i don't know just to worship god you
know it's a good thing and uh
thank you for all of the prayers and um
encouraging texts and just y'all were
wonderful to us our um
we have kind of not just our family but
we have like a household because we live
with my um
brother and sister-in-law and their four
kiddos and so
um we had a bout of cove that we went
through over the last you know two weeks
and
um
it looks like everyone's gonna be okay
but it was it was just you know it's a
lot and um
and and then on top of that you know of
course like was mentioned it's kind of
you know it's just been bad in this area
and so i don't know kind of your exact
life situation or family friends but at
least in my world it's not good you know
we just got
you know aunts and people and um friends
and
you know i see you and it's just it's
just a lot you know
um
so all that to say i'm i'm just grateful
for the support the encouragement the
love that y'all showed us thank you
um yeah it meant a lot and
it's nice you know to to um
to be in a in a place that just cares
you know so thank you for caring and
um
yeah it was it was great to receive you
know as the pastor i do a lot of a lot
of text sending a lot of calling
checking in on others it was really cool
to have you all like reaching out brett
you okay you doing are you hanging in
there you know is really cool so um yeah
so thank you for that um so i was
thinking about
oh and i also want to welcome those join
us online love you all lots thank you
for being here um and if you're um new
here thanks for for joining us tonight
so i i thought a lot about this message
because we're wrapping up our
deconstruction series
and um
and just kind of how to to end it so um
for those not in the loop so
deconstruction it's kind of this term
that's come to mean um a season of
really doubt and wrestling with
inherited received
theology and beliefs you know we all
kind of pick it up even honestly those
who um actually i'll tell a story later
in the message
uh about someone who attends our church
but like wasn't didn't really even grow
up in church and yet still had all sorts
of ideas about god and
christ and church and what church you
know folks thought about him and you
know there's like a whole theology so um
you know we we just we just pick it up
it's just it's in the culture it's in
the air in the water so to speak um and
you know some of it's good and beautiful
and true and some of it not so much you
know some of it it destroys us like it
tears people down it beats them down
it's it's there can be shame and
condemnation and a lot of pain
associated with these things so this
series has really been about wrestling
through and working through
some of those things that that really
push people towards deconstruction
um you know whether it's certain
particular views of the bible um which
then kind of force you to give kind of a
thumbs up to like
violence and
even divine violence in the bible or um
you know hell understood as eternal
conscious torture forever and ever and
ever you know um i mean i could just
there's all sorts of things so if you um
have missed you can go back in the
series and listen to
um various messages but
the that's kind of the idea is that we
have to work through that stuff and so i
was kind of really thinking this week um
kind of why is that like
where
where is all of our deconstruction where
is it going um and so that's what i want
to talk about tonight uh as we wrap up
so it's titled the end of deconstruction
the end of deconstruction and um our
text is going to be galatians chapter
four um verses six through seven
this is the early christian missionary
pastor theologian paul
uh wrote these words to a little a
little church or a collection of
churches kind of scattered around this
roman province known as
galatia
he says because you
are his sons and implied there is
daughters
god sent the spirit of his son
into our hearts the spirit who calls out
abba father abba is aramaic for father
or papa
abba father
verse 7 so you are no longer a slave
but god's child when you use that
language of slave he'll talk later in
the chapter about being how they were
kind of enslaved to idolatry
and you know to live in the ancient
world was to live in fear of the gods
you know lowercase g gods
it was the the gods were kind of
everywhere and you don't want to get on
the bad side of the gods you know so
there's a lot of fear and anxiety over
did i do the right sacrifice did i
appease the proper god i mean i appeased
this one but maybe i missed one you know
and there was just a lot of that was
kind of how it was to live in the
ancient world so he's saying look you're
no you're no longer slaves but you're
god's capital g the one true god god's
child and since you are his child god
has made you also an heir
so one of the great privileges of my
life is that like i mentioned i get to
to live with my brother and
sister-in-law and that means i get to
see my brother-in-law's name is josh
josh reynolds and i get to watch him
raise his kids he's a good he's a good
dad um you know like any dad he's not
perfect he has his moments you know we
all do um but on the whole he's just
he's a good dad and i had this um sweet
moment i mean it was it was one of those
um just little moments but like if you
can see the beauty in it you know it was
one of those kind of moments not snazzy
or not some wow but it was just it was
profound um and his it was his little
girl her name's shiloh
and she's four
and um in the past few weeks he's done a
lot of parenting um with mindy um down
with kovid so lots of you know parenting
opportunities and this is just one of
those little moments where um he'd been
i mean caring for kids you know all day
and um
and we're at dinner
and shiloh looks at him and says uh you
know in her cute i mean she was really
she knows how to turn on the charm you
know so she made her cutest little face
and she did her cutest little voice and
she said daddy he said what shiloh she
said
after dinner
can we go swimming
and uh i was thinking in that moment
like i knew what i would say i was so
tired i'm sure he was tired i'd probably
just be like i'm sorry it's just not a
good night you know um but he's a good
dad he looked at her and he said
yeah
yeah we can go swimming
and then this look you know she's just
like oh she just i mean she was over the
moon it's like the best thing you know
so we eat dinner and i'm doing some
dishes and i look out the window and i
can see some many of y'all have been to
our house so i got the straight shot all
the way kind of through the courtyard
and in the backyard and there's the pool
and i look and there's josh shiloh's got
her little hands you know it was like
the classic little four-year-old kind of
where you just grab her on the neck
just holding on for dear life he's
zooming around the shallow end kind of
trying to throw her off he's not trying
very hard i mean he could easily he is
pretty strong you know okay uh so
he's just zooming around and she's
holding on for dear life
and he does this one kind of spin and i
get just a glimpse of her face and this
was the moment where
just her face there was a look of
how do you describe it like such
kind of delight
and joy
and you know she's laughing and
it was like in that moment you could
just see
that she knew that she knew that she
knew
that she was loved
and that little smile it's so infectious
i mean i'm standing there
looking that somehow it just reaches
across the courtyard
and hits my face and suddenly i'm
smiling this huge smile
and it was just one of those little
moments in life of just true
beauty
and
grace
and when we reflect on these writings
from the apostle paul in galatians
chapter 4
when he says that god sent the spirit
into our hearts the spirit who calls out
abba father
what what paul is describing there
is this i don't think it's so much a
moment though for some people maybe
that's their experience like it just
hits them i think for most of us though
it is a very slow
but steady
um
kind of dawny like a dawning realization
um that that just kind of steals in upon
us and it's this um it's this
this process where i mean how does it
happen it's a bit of a mystery you know
through hearing the scriptures through
moments like we just had this song known
and loved known and loved and it just it
just starts seeping in to our bones it
happens um
for some of you in therapy
you know known and loved known and loved
in the in the listening ear of a
therapist i had a i was in seminary and
was taught by a therapist about pastoral
counseling and someone asked what do you
think about secular counseling
the professor said i don't think there's
any such thing
i thought that was a beautiful answer
because he's not saying of course that
everyone like every counselor says bible
verses well of course not but god is
there
god is there in that listening you had
so how does this happen it just
it's a mystery but a thousand ways
conversations
um
even i was thinking of christian
community i experienced it as i just
talked about the texts and the calls and
the meals and the checking in
um it's like this process
of just loving one another not perfectly
the lord knows we can't do that and this
isn't a perfect church
but but just as best we can and and
somehow in that process there's like
some magic that happens
god just meets us and it just it just
starts to seep in
where we know that we know
that we know
that we're loved
and when i
when i think about
um deconstruction
you know because we've been in this
series now for two months um when i
think about deconstruction and and i
kind of ask the question what is the end
of all of our deconstructing like where
is it going what's its what's its
purpose
um i think
that at its best
that's that's kind of its purpose
that it helps us receive these truths
and though it's a little bit difficult
and at times even kind of emotionally
violent for anyone who's been through a
season of doubt of wrestling of
struggling like it's not you know i can
make it sound sort of beautiful um
where it takes you is beautiful
you know in the midst in the moment just
slightly hellish
you know it's hard to question things
like the deep things the things that are
like the foundation of your whole life
and world that's like a big freaking
deal you know what i mean like it's not
like fun
um
but it's meaningful
and it's
and because god's in it i think it's
beautiful
and it takes us somewhere
um if i had to kind of sum it up i'd say
that i think deconstruction at its best
you know it is idol smashing
it is a tearing down
a throwing away of everything that holds
us back from the god who is love
i think i think that's
kind of the heartbeat of it like that's
that's at least when it works well
you know at its best because of course
it can be just a pure negation it can be
just a pure um just a pure no and i
reject that and i reject that and i
reject that and that's bad and that's
the worst and you know all these
christians are you know and
there's some truth in that you know like
i'm not saying that that's all wrong um
but at its best though it's not just a
no
but it's also this it's it's a no so
that i can move towards the yes
you know it's this
this throwing away of this tearing down
of everything that would hold me back
hold us back from the god who is love
that is the the god
whose face we've come to see in the face
of jesus
and when i think of um
where that takes us
it it's that
that settledness
starts to seep into our bones
and
suddenly
we can um
i think hear
things again as though for the first
time
you know because like there's a season
where we're just kind of in that
reactionary
agitated mode and it's just easy for
everything to hack us off you know i
remember there was a season where um
when i was in my own deconstruction
about 12 years ago i couldn't go well i
shouldn't say i couldn't go to church i
did go to church i was the guy who went
and sat at the back
because my kids should go to church you
know so i did that
and i remember how everything would just
hack me off so i could just agitating
annoying cliche you know just oh
i just oh just burned me up
and again there's a season for that you
know like there's a grace for that um
maybe even some of you have had a little
bit of those moments either in the past
at the table or even tonight something
might have kind of triggered you just
like oh gosh you know
um and yet i think the end of
deconstruction
is so beautiful it's its purpose its
goal is so beautiful because it helps us
slowly but surely exit
that reactionary place almost helps us
kind of work it through and get it out
of our system such that we can hear
the
truth of christ again as though for the
first time
and and it allows us even to hear the
bible
um
where things that might have just really
triggered us and like ah
you know and it allows us to like
hear it
um with those fresh ears i think for
example of like john 3 16.
you know this kind of simple
but so such a beautiful passage like for
god so loved the world
that he gave his one and only son
that whoever believes in him should not
perish but have everlasting or eternal
life
and when we're in the the construction
season it's easy to react probably to
that word perish that we might guess as
to what someone be like what does that
mean perish you know i know what that's
talking about hell hellfire that's
everything that i hate about sure you
know or whatever the
sorry i don't mean to like mock it if
i'm i'm trying to get the emotion of the
person who's in that mode you know
partly because again i've been there i
know exactly what i was feeling on the
inside even though if on the outside i
played it cool but you know on the
inside oh my gosh there's a season where
i couldn't barely read the bible because
it would just i would like read sections
and be like yes i love this and then all
of a sudden just be like
what is that you know it's words like
perish
and
and yet if we could work it through if
we could start to understand
um
god's heart then all of a sudden
i mean honestly we're just able to chill
out a little bit you know and become
less reactionary and be able to see that
the whole point of that verse for
example is for god's so loved
right it's sort of like we don't hear
that part we just hear the perish and
then it kind of colors the whole text
instead of for god so loved the world
like his whole heart is that no one
should perish
um that's the whole and so we can
suddenly hear it again and start to
receive it as something like beautiful
and true i think um
also of romans 8 1
uh this is paul again where he says
there is therefore now no condemnation
for those who are in christ jesus and
it's like
after we've deconstructed and pulled
down all the idols and the crazy insane
images of god that we've had maybe from
childhood sunday school or something and
we kind of work it through and we just
see the beauty of who the
lord jesus is then suddenly we hear a
verse like that it's like for the first
time again it's so
beautiful
um
or first timothy we hear again the
apostle paul when he says in first
timothy 1 15 christ jesus came into the
world to save sinners
of whom i am the worst
and again when we're in the season of
deconstruction
we might kind of hear that like see
that's that negative i'm a worm i'm
nothing i'm the worst i'm judged by god
right and you can see how we can go down
that road but once we work it through
and we get
kind of our image of god more jesus-like
then suddenly we can hear that actually
paul can say that precisely because
he knows that he knows that he knows
that he's loved and so from a place of
humility
he can say
like and i just might be the worst of
all
and yet he can receive god's grace
it's after deconstruction that we can
hear again first john 4 10 in this is
love not that we loved god but that he
loved us and sent his son to be the
atonement for our sins
and again when we're in midst of
deconstruction we didn't do a message on
this but we we could have on atonement
and are you saying that god wanted to
vent his wrath upon the sun he was like
some sort of divine child abuser and you
know this is like a completely
untrinitarian view of the cross but this
is kind of what we hear at times
and yet what the whole point is like no
no no no dear heart like calm down
the
the image there is it's to cast out fear
right it's like because for god so loved
like that's the heart
not god venting you had to hurt someone
you know like whoa whoa no
that's no
no
so we can hear it again
in other words once we've done some
deconstructing
we just might be able to hear galatians
4 6 again that brothers
because you are his sons and his
daughters god sent the spirit of his son
into our hearts the spirit who calls out
abba father
deconstruction it's it's idol smashing
it's this tearing down of everything
that holds us back from the love of god
and you know by god's grace
it's happening
here
slowly but surely some of you um had the
great privilege of being at our very
first baptism service a month ago
and
it was it was remarkable to hear the
stories i wanted to share two um two
with you tonight before we wrap up
and um i did get permission from these
folks to share their stories
so the first is a gentleman named adam
adam goes to the table everyone loves
adam
and um
so adam was who i was referencing
earlier so he
didn't grow up really you know going to
church or anything like that
but
just being in the culture
um
because of his sexual orientation he had
picked up this basically idea that god
was against him and um
that that
that really probably at the end of his
days he would be tortured in hell
forever that was just kind of his
theology
um
and so he even though he didn't grow up
like in a church environment he just
picked it up
and
yet
something was like drawing him
to
god which is strange to say right like i
had this image of god that's like so
horrible and yet something in me is like
longing for
the more the
and so he did just a search and and
searched for churches in his area found
the table
um
walked through the doors
and
i mean what a beautiful transformation
if you've been able to walk or just get
to know adam like just slowly but surely
over the last two years he's just
started to learn that that idea those
like he's
deconstructed and that those images of
god that by way of thinking of god is
like not jesus e at all and that
actually he's a son of the living god
in in
in the spirit
of god is like crying out from within
him abba father
papa father
and adam will now he'll text me
occasionally just finished praying
just finished meditating you know like
it's it's so cool to see him kind of
finding finding his way
i think also of um
of marissa
she shared so beautifully at the baptism
service she had written out
her story i'm going to read this is just
the second kind of paragraph of her
story
she said as a gay woman
i carry significant hurt
and damage from judgment and exclusion
from christians and church in general
i also carry incredible hurt and trauma
from lgbtq christians excluding me and
acting anything but christ-like towards
me this is a uniquely horrific pain i
expected to carry to my grave
but over the past year and a half i've
slowly come to realize that the table
and the people within it are a healing
balm that i never could have imagined
into existence for myself
my baptism today in this place is also a
sign of my commitment to this church and
to each of you here with me thank you
for for celebrating and encouraging me
and most of all for loving me
unconditionally
and reflecting the love of christ to me
can you hear it
you hear the spirit calls out from
within us abba father
papa father
how does it happen like what's the
formula
no formula
just mystery of mystery it is some
mysterious concoction of of scripture
and prayer and quiet and study and
therapy in community in music
and i mean
and somehow
god just does it
and just to be clear god does it all
over the world this isn't just about the
table oh what a special church we are
this never happens anywhere else it
totally happens
a lot of other places too god god is
doing his thing jesus is present in the
world
and so you see this is um this is the
end of all of our deconstructing it is
if you if you've been around the table
for a while you know that our mission is
to shift a generation from reactionary
to visionary to the person and work of
jesus and when i think of deconstruction
i think that's the process i go from
this reactionary i've got a bone to pick
with god you know i don't like what god
thinks or at least what i think god
thinks about such topics or people or
whatever and we gotta work it through
and that's okay there's grace there's
room for that like we need that season
but we work it through so we can shift
out of that reactionary mode and into
that visionary christ-like um
mode where we start to feel again the
love of god bubbling up from within us
the spirit inside us calling out abba
father
that's the end of all of our
deconstructing
and so um to close i want to pray this
prayer this is from saint patrick
and every time it says the word christ i
want you to um
just kind of close your eyes and imagine
the love of god filling you
that's what i'd like us to do is that
okay
all right let me pray
christ with me
christ before me
christ behind me
christ in me
christ beneath me christ above me
christ on my right
christ on my left
christ when i lie down
christ when i sit down
christ in the heart of everyone who
thinks of me christ in the mouth of
everyone who speaks of me
christ in the eye that sees me
christ in the ear that hears me
i
arise today
church we
arise today through the mighty strength
of the lord
of creation
amen
[Music]
you surround me
with
a song
of deliverance
from my enemies
till all my
fears and i'm no longer
a slave to fear
[Music]
i'm no
longer a slave to fear
cause i am a child of god
[Music]
from my mother's womb
you have chosen me
and love
[Music]
to your family
your blood flows
[Music]
a
child of god
i'm no
longer a slave to
[Music]
a fear
of god let's sing that again i'm no
longer i'm no longer
cause i
am a
child of god
i'm no
[Music]
longer fear
cause i
am a
child of god
[Music]
oh
my fears
[Music]
so i could walk right through
my fears
me so i could stand and sing
i am
[Music]
and i'm no longer
a
slave to fear
cause i am a child
of god
thank you so much for being here tonight
i hope that every part of the service
blessed you in some way
reminded you of the love of god and
reminded you that you are not alone
don't forget about our state of the
table meeting next week immediately
after the service
and also if
you need some prayer tonight or just
somebody to to talk to please come find
me
i would love to talk with you and and
pray for you
lastly before we dismiss if you could
stand if you're comfortable doing so
i'd like to leave you with this
benediction
as you go out from here
i didn't plan this this way i mean i say
this every time i'm up here at the end
but
it's really fitting with this song so i
hope it really
really resonates with you tonight
you
are a child of god
are a child
of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true
on your worst day
so as you go out from here
into the week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in between
go with the assurance
that you are loved
you are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the desire to extend these same gifts of
unconditional love and grace to everyone
you come in contact with this week
remember everybody is carrying a burden
some people are suffering silently and
let's all be good and gentle with one
another
have a great week hope to see you back
here next sunday good night
[Music]
oh
you rescued me so i could stand and sing
i am
a child of god
you split the sea so i could walk right
through
it
[Music]
i am
a
[Music]
i
am
[Music]
awesome